I have a tendency
to want to do a little bit of everything.
Gymnastics,
music,
comedy...
But, I'm starting to realize
there are serious drawbacks
to dabbling in too many hobbies.
Because you get good at a bunch of random stuff,
but you don't get GREAT at any one thing.
I was reading that it takes 10,000 hours,
roughly 10 years, of hard work and deliberate practice
to become a master of something.
And so it makes you wonder,
what do you want to be great at?
What do you want to be a master of?
And I decided...
Storytelling.
Because that emcompasses
everything that I love.
Acting,
Writing,
Directing...
I don't care, I just want to be a part of telling
a great story.
So, that's part of the reason
why I'm doing the minimum of 12 short films this year,
not only is it a great education,
but I feel like it'll really help me hone in
on my focus and make me remember
"No, THIS is what you wanna work on."
Speaking of which,
my first one came out last week!
It's called "Hallucination,"
and it's about a girl with schizophernia
who's stalked by a figment of her imagination.
It was so much fun to film.
Yeah!
I'm on tape, tape!
Such a great learning experience.
I'm-I'm a director.
And, I have this Satan-like footage
for the rest of my life...
(whispering)
Kill her, kill her, kill her...
(voice increases)
KILL HER, KILL HER, KILL HER....
I will see you next week.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
AAAHH.